as you heard i come from zagreb croatia
which is a former yugoslav republic and
i have been working in documenta which
is a center for dealing with the past 45
years almost five years now and I am
here to talk about this oral history
project called unveiling a personal
memory of war and tension in Croatia
from 1941 until present but first I
would like to say a bit more about
documenta I will give you a short
overview of our work because i think
it's it's important for you to hear what
we do so you can better understand the
concept and the objectives of of this
oral history project and maybe later in
our discussion you can ask me some
questions about that if you find some of
our other projects interesting to you so
as I said documenta is the NGO from
Croatia which was established and in
2004 in an attempt to encourage personal
and social processes of dealing with the
past and in Croatia and sometimes even
wider
region and to establish Pactual truth
about war crimes and other war related
events in creation and key reason for
making such an attempt was this I would
say a long tradition of silence war
crimes and other poor events from the
from the past that means primarily that
after the Second World War when
socialist federative republic of
yugoslavia established the main official
narrative was the one to talk about only
partisans and partisan movement and
monuments were erected for great
partisans schools and factories and
streets were named after them because it
was Bobby I was celebrating this huge
anti-fascist movement which is one of
the biggest and fascist movements in the
world during the Second World War so
nobody mentioned the victims especially
not the victims of Mustafa and technique
when the Home Guard
troops across all yugoslavia and
especially not the mass murders of those
troops as well as the as well as some
civilians and the end of the war in 1945
when they were all killed because of the
crimes they committed in 1941 but their
casualties have never been documented by
personal identification second second
group of crimes that were kept and quiet
during the US war period were crimes in
which Yugoslav government imprisoned
many people in the island of Bali or
goalie auto in creation and those were
mainly citizens of Yugoslavia who were
convicted of taking science side after
in 1948 stallion NT top in broke broke
up their relationship after the in form
below resolution and you have all these
issues from Yugoslavia and then in the
90s there are wars in Bosnia hurts
rina and croatia and slovenia again so
now we have this tradition of silence
about crimes in during those wars also
when it comes to creation that usually
means that nobody talks about Serbian
victims in creation the main or the
predominant narrative is about creation
victims Misha although there were many
Serbian victims especially in the end of
the war in 1995 when with operation
store the majority of occupied rationed
territories were liberated by creation
army and some syrup civilians were
killed so I gave your short overview of
historical problems that we have and why
documenta is doing what we are doing so
because of all that since its
establishment
has been systematically contributing to
development of social and individual
processes of dealing with the past
mainly with different projects in which
we are documenting initiating public
dialogue monitoring war crimes and so on
and in order to achieve our goals we are
of course cooperating with many other
organizations raesha with
non-governmental organizations
government institution local government
institutions media religious groups and
of course any other interested
individual now I will tell you I will
highlight a few documentas most relevant
projects documented works through three
different programs which are the
documenting public policies and public
dialogue and improvement of judicial
practices and standards which means that
we are systematically monitoring war
crimes trials in Croatia and in region
from 2004 together with two other
organizations from creation Civic
committee for Human Rights from Zagreb
and center for peace nonviolent and
human rights from 06 so my joint forces
we are monitoring the war crimes trials
in order to publish reports on those
trials and
Kate improvement in changes in
traditional system as well in the
witness support system in Croatia we are
also monitoring the work of State
Attorney's Office and Croatia and also
monitoring proceedings for the state for
non materials non-material damages
claims which means that some people in
Croatia are suing the state of Croatia
for their nan nan material losses from
the war and in majority of cases that
means that those people are obligated to
pay enormous amounts of money because
their claims in these proceedings were
were rejected so we have a lot of a lot
of work to do with court system
concerning war crimes in Croatia and the
main goal is to assure the rule of law
in Croatian when it comes to war crime
trials by improving the legal framework
and increasing efficiency
work of the course as well as making the
role of victims in this processes better
in the whole system when it comes to
programs of public dialogue and public
policies we have projects concerning
teaching of history preparations
cultural memory projects but the main
project the biggest project project i
want to mention to you is coalition for
establishment it's a long day as a good
establishment River Regional Commission
for truth telling and truth seeking
about war crimes and in short Rackham is
an initiative of a coalition of more
than one 1800 NGOs from the region
individuals and associations of victims
who advocated the establishment of
independent interstate or regional as
you wish official non-political
commission with a mission to collect
they talk about war crimes that were
committed in yorba slavia and other
major violations of human rights in the
period from 1991 until 2001 and of
course resolving the fate of missing
persons and locating their mortal
remains as you probably already know
this this initiative for this commission
is modeled on other Truth and
Reconciliation Commission that we
already have or had in turn heading in
the world such as the one in in South
Africa sierra leone canada and so on the
idea about this commission was or the
coalition was founded in 2008 in
pristine in kosovo by three
organizations from region documenta from
zagreb committed humanitarian law center
from Belgrade and center for
documentation and research from Sarah
Hamilton I'm trying to translate it into
english in my head and the whole idea
behind this was the fact that these
organizations realized that war crimes
trials are the only legal instrument we
have in the Balkans that are for the
terminating individual liability for war
crimes and they knew that that isn't
enough to create a factual truth about
everything that happened during the war
so they finally after a few years of
debating what to do they finally decided
on choosing this mechanism of
transitional justice in their future
work
our third program is documenting and
this is the the most important of all of
our problems that's why we are called
mentum and we we decided on having this
program because of the fact that victims
of war aren't only number than people
with their names and families and their
personal stories so we started to the
document in human losses in croatia in
homeland war from 91 to 95 using
scientifically based methodology and
contemporary research techniques in
order to make a name by name list of all
victims racial regardless of their
ethnicity religion identity or any other
thing and of course we are planning to
publicly publish those documents we
collect and the key reason or the main
what motive why we are doing this is the
fact that even more than 15 years after
the
the war in Croatia there isn't still one
isn't still undisputable or verifiable
list of all victims in the world in
creation which means that government
didn't do it so far and as you already
know of course when you don't have the
exact number of victims it's a really
good feel for different political and
ideological manipulations with the
number of victims so by implementing
this project we wanted to do to stop it
we wanted to make impossible Falls and
arbitrary speculations about war victims
and in Croatia and the other thing
that's important to say about this
project is that my collecting data we
are
giving some relevant data to relevant
judicial institution in creation and in
that way we are helping to individualize
the responsibility for certain war crime
scene creation so that about it about me
or the most important in project
documentum and now talk about finally
about this oral history project work why
we over here so as you heard the project
is called a milling personal memory on
Warren attention in Croatia from 1941
until present sorry and this is the this
is a project that proposes the use of
oral history as a method in order to
collect and open up individual memories
on past traumatic events from different
perspectives the key reason for such an
effort is the one that I mentioned
before and that is all these silence
more events from before which have
significantly influenced all of our
societies posted some countries
we'll certainly and necessarily reflect
on future generations also so therefore
we want to firm personal memories of all
interested witnesses and protagonist of
historical events in creation and
preserve them in from permanent loss the
main idea behind this project or our
great belief is that true recording and
transferring subjective experiences it
is possible to get a deeper insight into
seemingly hidden aspects of political
turmoil and conflict and that such point
project will increase personal and
social processes of dealing with the
past which we find a crucial
precondition for sustainable peace in
societies the other thing is that we
also strongly believe that with
revealing and disseminating the variety
of perspectives on how war effects and
individual
we can contribute to a better
understanding what are the servant
circumstances that can lead to collapse
of the society and consequently to war
so in this project we are collecting a
recording video interviews creation so
far we have recorded more than 400
interviews and all of the interviews are
transcribed and translated and uploaded
on an open internet platform